This is not a setting where Chris was used to learning anything important, much less having his whole world rocked by something somebody said. He was 15, in health class, in San Juan Capistrano, California. As Chris remembers it, it was the beginning of the period. Class was just beginning to settle down. The teacher was also the school's basketball coach.
这并不是克里斯习惯学习重要知识的场合，更不用说被别人的话彻底颠覆世界观了。那时他15岁，在加利福尼亚州圣胡安-卡皮斯特拉诺上健康课。据克里斯回忆，那是上课刚开始的时候，教室里正逐渐安静下来。老师同时也是学校的篮球队教练。
You know, in my memory, he's the standard-issue-- I don't know-- tallish, white guy coach with, like, neatly parted brown hair. And the bell rings. Class is supposed to start. And we're all just talking over him, not listening.
你知道，在我的记忆中，他就是那种标准的——我不知道该怎么形容——个子高高的、白人教练形象，留着整齐的中分棕色头发。铃声响了，课本该开始了，但我们都在各聊各的，没人在听他说话。
And he's trying to get class started. And I think he's getting, understandably, a little annoyed. And then at one point, one of the girls said loudly, we're all going to be friends forever.
他试图让课堂开始，我想他理所当然地感到有点烦躁。就在这时，有个女生大声说：“我们大家要永远做朋友。”
And then he gets our attention and said something like, just for your information, you're not going to all stay friends forever. And let me tell you a little bit about how friendships work. He says, in a couple of years, high school is going to end, and you're going to all scatter to different jobs or colleges, and you're going to start falling out of touch with each other, and eventually, you're not going to talk to most of any of these other people. And now, you might--
然后他吸引了我们的注意，说了类似这样的话：“顺便告诉你们，你们不可能永远都是朋友。让我告诉你们友谊是怎么运作的。”他说，几年后，高中生活就会结束，你们会各奔东西，去不同的工作岗位或大学，你们会开始失去联系，最终，你们中的大多数人都不会再和这些人说话了。现在，你们可能——
(LAUGHING) Can we just pause? That is such-- it's real. It's very true. But what a funny thing to say to a bunch of kids.
（笑声）我们可以先暂停一下吗？这真是……太现实了，非常真实。但对一群孩子说这种话也太有趣了。
Yeah. It's like, suddenly, he had our full attention.
是啊。就像他突然吸引了我们全部的注意力一样。
But then the teacher kept going. He wasn't done. He got very specific and said, OK, you might stay in touch with a few friends from high school.
但老师还没说完，他继续道：“好吧，你们也许会和高中里的几个朋友保持联系。”
He said, like, well, then you're going to get into your 30s and your 40s, and it'll be harder. You'll be working. And then some of you might get married, and your free time-- a lot of that should go towards your spouse. And if you have kids, oh, whatever little free time you have left, that'll go to the kids.
他说：“好吧，然后你们会进入30多岁和40多岁，那时会更困难。你们要工作，有些人可能会结婚，而你们的空闲时间……很大一部分应该留给配偶。如果你们有了孩子，噢，剩下的那点可怜的空闲时间，就都得花在孩子身上了。”
And finally, he said, the only friends you're going to be left with are the parents of whatever kid your little toddler or whatever randomly sidles up to because they both like the same part of the playground. That person, that parent-- that's going to be your friend.
最后他说：“你们剩下的唯一朋友，将是你们的蹒跚学步的孩子在操场上随便撞见、因为恰好喜欢同一片场地而结识的那个孩子的父母。那个人，那个家长……那才是你们以后的朋友。”
That is a very thorough and vivid and not inaccurate picture of the future, that it's amazing that he went into that much detail.
这是一幅非常透彻、生动且并不失实的未来图景，他能讲得如此细致真是令人惊叹。
Yes. By then, we were like-- I remember a sort of, like, stunned silence at that point. And maybe there's one person who said, like, no, or like, no, he's wrong, or we're going to stay friends, or something. And then the class-- and then the class began, and I don't remember anything else from that day.
是的。那时候我们就像是……我记得那一刻有一种惊愕的沉默。也许有个人说“不”，或者说“不，他是错的，我们要一直做朋友”之类的。然后课就开始了，那天剩下的内容我什么都不记得了。
This is actually one of the producers on our show, Chris Benderev. And he says he remembers the other kids in class, kind of, shrugging this off like, yeah, whatever. But he couldn't.
这位其实是我们节目的制片人之一，克里斯·本德雷夫。他说他记得班上其他孩子都耸耸肩，觉得“好吧，随它去吧”。但他却做不到。
Did you think it was true?
你当时觉得他说的是真的吗？
Absolutely. I thought that he-- I remember thinking, oh, no, I hope that he's wrong, but it sounds like he's right. That's what I remember thinking. It had the air of truth, partly because it was so specific-- the playground detail, especially.
绝对是。我记得当时想，噢不，我希望他是错的，但他听起来像是对的。我记得当时是这么想的。那种话带有一种真实感，部分原因是因为它太具体了——尤其是关于操场细节的描述。
Before this moment, Chris hadn't bothered picturing what the future was going to be very much. He had a vague sense that things were going to get better and better. But now, thanks to this random speech by this otherwise forgotten teacher, he realized the future he was facing--
在此之前，克里斯从未费心去构想未来会是什么样子。他有一种模糊的感觉，觉得事情会越来越好。但现在，多亏了这位本来已经被人遗忘的老师的随口一说，他意识到了他即将面对的未来——
It's going to get tedious and small and narrow and boring. Because when you're in high school, what is better than hanging out with your friends?
它会变得沉闷、渺小、狭窄且无聊。因为当你上高中的时候，有什么能比和朋友们厮混更好呢？
Right.
对。
Like, that was the best thing you could do. And so you're going to have less and less of that, and this tiny world where you don't even get to pick your friends. I don't know. That just seemed very sad at the time-- and scary, a little bit.
就像，那是你能做的最好的事。而以后你会有越来越少的这种时光，处在一个连朋友都无法自己选择的狭小世界里。我不知道，那时候这看起来真的很悲伤——而且有点吓人。
In fact, as senior year approached, as graduation day approached, Chris says that this tiny, two-minute speech by this teacher totally colored how he was seeing it. He loved his friends.
事实上，随着高三临近，随着毕业日临近，克里斯说这位老师那两分钟的随口发言完全影响了他对未来的看法。他很爱他的朋友们。
I was scared of the end of high school in a way that I think most 18-year-olds aren't. It seemed like this was going to be the beginning of the end. And so I became very kind of nostalgic and also fearful, like a doomsday clock or something was running down.
我当时害怕高中生活的结束，这种程度我觉得大多数18岁的人都不会有。这看起来像是终结的开始。所以我变得非常怀旧，同时也感到恐惧，就像有一个末日时钟在倒计时一样。
Chris actually checked on the health teacher recently. And of course, he had no memory of making that speech, though he said it was exactly the kind of thing that he might have said. And in fact, he did remember saying it at some point to his own kids.
克里斯最近真的去核实了那位健康老师的情况。当然，他根本不记得自己说过那番话，尽管他说那确实是他可能会说的话。事实上，他在某个时刻确实对自己的孩子说过同样的话。
This teacher said that he would like to believe that he meant it in a kind of nice, "cherish these special times" sort of way, and he was horrified at the thought that this made Chris or any other kid feel bad for the rest of high school. But it just goes to show you how somebody can say something off the cuff that can accidentally turn somebody else's world completely upside down.
这位老师说他希望自己当时表达的是一种善意，意在“珍惜这些特殊时光”，他对那番话让克里斯或其他孩子在高中余下时间里感到难过感到震惊。但这也说明，一个人随口说出的话，是如何在无意间彻底颠覆另一个人世界的。
We asked listeners if they ever experienced this, and hundreds responded. Some of the sentences that were said casually to them that later, alone, they obsessed over.
我们询问听众是否经历过这种情况，数百人做出了回应。有些话是别人随口对他们说的，后来他们却独自纠结了很久。
"It's not your glasses that are uneven. It's your face."
“不是你的眼镜戴歪了，是你的脸歪了。”
"You must have been surrounded by some pretty insensitive people growing up."
“你长大过程中一定是被一群相当迟钝的人包围着。”
"No, no, you're the only circumcised one in the family."
“不，不，你是家里唯一割过包皮的人。”
And one last one, said by a childhood acquaintance at a funeral. "Jenny, little Jenny, you're the one that nobody liked."
还有最后一条，是一个儿时熟人在葬礼上说的：“珍妮，小珍妮，你是那个没人喜欢的人。”
In Chris's case, the teacher's comment obviously stayed with him.
在克里斯的案例中，老师的评论显然留在了他的心里。
How old are you now?
你现在多大了？
I am 38.
我38岁。
And how many friends from high school are you in touch with?
那你和多少高中朋友还有联系？
I-- a few. A few.
我……几个。几个吧。
Count.
数一数。
Three or four. Three or four. And really, only one that I see regularly.
三四个。三四个。真正经常见面的其实只有一个。
So the guy was right.
所以那家伙是对的。
Yes, he was absolutely right. He-- 100%. [CHUCKLES] He fully predicted my future.
是的，他绝对是对的。他……百分之百正确。（轻笑）他完全预测了我的未来。
These days, Chris is married. One child.
如今，克里斯结婚了，有一个孩子。
In fact, my-- the only friends I've made recently are the parents of the other kids who are in my son's daycare.
事实上，我最近交到的唯一朋友就是我儿子日托班其他孩子的父母。
Yeah. And in fact, now that you are married and have children, is your life tedious and narrow and boring?
是的。那么，现在你结婚生子了，你的生活是否沉闷、狭窄且无聊呢？
In some ways, it is. But I like it. I really like it.
在某些方面确实是。但我喜欢这样，我真的很喜欢。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I obviously like spending time with my kid and my wife. And the people I made friends with that are the parents of the kids randomly assigned to my kid's daycare class-- yeah, they're delightful.
我显然很喜欢和我孩子、妻子在一起的时光。而那些我结识的朋友，那些随机分配到我儿子日托班的孩子的父母——他们确实很讨人喜欢。
Today on our program, "If You Want to Destroy My Sweater, Hold This Thread As I Walk Away." We have stories about the things that people say that unravel your world, turn it upside down, shake it like a snow globe-- pick your own metaphor for this.
今天我们的节目主题是“如果你想毁了我的毛衣，在我走开时扯住这根线”。我们讲述了一些人们说的话，这些话会拆解你的世界，将其颠覆，像摇晃雪花球一样震动它——随你怎么比喻。
Some of these off-hand things that people say are completely accurate. Others are the exact opposite. And it can be really hard sometimes to tell which is which. We have real-life case examples, including somebody who thinks his life was completely upended after a single, brief, real-life encounter with Weezer. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
有些随口说出的话是完全准确的。另一些则恰恰相反。有时要分清哪是哪真的很难。我们有现实生活中的案例，包括一个人认为在与威瑟乐队（Weezer）有过一次短暂的现实接触后，他的人生被彻底颠覆了。来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, The World Has Turned and Left Me Here. So let's kick off this show about people saying things that unravel your picture of the world with this, from Lilly Sullivan.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，世界转动，将我留在此处。那么，让我们从莉莉·沙利文的这个故事开始，开启这一期关于人们的话语如何瓦解你对世界认知的故事。
In my family, there's a story, the kind your family never forgets. It's about a hitchhiker. It happened decades ago, in 1974. There were three women in the car-- my aunt Manuelita, her daughter, and their cousin. Manuelita was driving.
在我们家，有一个故事，那种你全家永远都不会忘记的故事。是关于一个搭便车的人。事情发生在几十年前，1974年。车里有三个女人——我的姨妈曼努埃利塔、她的女儿和她们的表亲。曼努埃利塔在开车。
And I was going in my car. And then here, I saw him hitchhiking like this.
我当时开着车。然后在这儿，我看见他在搭便车，就像这样。
Holding his finger in the air.
把手指举在空中。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Manuelita is now 96, and her daughter in the car, Anita, remembers more of the details. So I'm going to let Anita tell a lot of this. She was a kid at the time, 10 years old.
曼努埃利塔现在96岁了，当时在车里的女儿安妮塔记得更多细节。所以我打算让安妮塔来讲讲这个故事的大部分。她当时是个孩子，10岁。
For me, it was such a shocking event. It permeated every cell of my being, meaning, like, I just remember it all very clearly. We were in the car. My mother was driving, and she was always impeccably dressed if she was going out.
对我来说，那是一个如此震撼的事件。它渗透了我全身的每一个细胞，意思是，我记得非常清楚。我们当时在车里。我妈妈在开车，她出门时总是打扮得无可挑剔。
And, um, it was raining that day. My mother exited the freeway, and she spotted this young man hitchhiking. He was tall and lanky, and he had long, blonde, dirty blonde hair-- well, because it was wet. It was raining, you know.
那天正在下雨。我妈妈下了高速公路，看到那个年轻人在搭便车。他又高又瘦，留着长长的、金色的、肮脏的头发——嗯，因为头发是湿的。你知道，当时在下雨。
And his beard was just, like, down to his chest. And he had his shirt inside out and misbuttoned. And she said, oh, he has such kind eyes. And I was like, no, he doesn't. You can't see his eyes. It's raining.
他的胡子长到胸口。他把衬衫穿反了，扣子也扣错了。她说：“噢，他有一双多慈祥的眼睛啊。”我当时想：“不，他没有。你根本看不见他的眼睛。在下雨呢。”
And she said, no! I was not afraid of him.
她说：“不！我一点也不怕他。”
But she was.
但她其实怕的。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。（笑声）
Anita was scared because they were in Northern California, and there were serial killers-- a few of them-- around there in the '70s. Even at 10, Anita knew this. All three women in the car were small, all under five feet. Anita in the front seat, their cousin Cecilia in the back. Again, here's Anita.
安妮塔很害怕，因为他们在北加州，70年代那里有好几个连环杀手。即使在10岁时，安妮塔也知道这一点。车里的三个女人个子都很小，都不到五英尺。安妮塔坐在前座，她们的表亲塞西莉亚在后座。再说一遍，这是安妮塔的讲述。
And then, of course, I was protesting loudly. Don't stop the car! And Cecilia even said, no, Manuelita, don't do it. Don't do it.
当然，我当时在大声抗议。不要停车！塞西莉亚甚至说：“不，曼努埃利塔，别这么做。别做。”
Manuelita stopped anyway. The man came to the window.
曼努埃利塔还是停车了。那个男人走到车窗前。
And he had to talk through the passenger side window, where I was sitting and kind of, like, freaking out that he was in my face now.
他不得不隔着副驾驶的车窗说话，我就坐在那儿，因为他在我面前而感到有点抓狂。
Anita remembers sitting stock still, staring straight ahead, afraid to make eye contact as a stranger somehow talked them into letting him into the car.
安妮塔记得自己坐得笔直，目视前方，不敢和他对视，因为这个陌生人不知怎的就把她们说服了，让她们让他上了车。
And my mother didn't speak very good English. Neither did Cecelia. But guess who did speak Spanish?
我妈妈的英语说得不太好。塞西莉亚也不太好。但猜猜谁会说西班牙语？
Serial killer-looking white guy? Turns out, fluent in Spanish. The hitchhiker lumbered into the back seat next to Cecilia. Cecilia had only been in the country a few weeks at that point and was like, what on earth? She was 26.
那个长得像连环杀手的白人？结果，他竟然精通西班牙语。那个搭便车的人笨重地挤进后座，挨着塞西莉亚。塞西莉亚当时到这个国家才几周，心想“到底是怎么回事？”她当时26岁。
And Cecilia-- she was all dressed prim and proper, and she even had little white gloves on. And he had a booming personality to match a booming voice. He had a great voice.
塞西莉亚当时穿得整整齐齐，甚至戴着白色的小手套。而他有着与之洪亮的嗓音相匹配的洪亮个性。他声音很好听。
He got in the car, and everybody calmed down when we heard him speak to Cecilia so kindly, and my mother introduced them. And she pointed out that she had just come.
他上车后，我们听到他那么友善地和塞西莉亚说话，大家就都镇定下来了，我妈妈介绍了他们。她提到塞西莉亚刚到这里。
Cecilia had just come to the US from Peru. And this is how the story started.
塞西莉亚刚从秘鲁来到美国。故事就是这样开始的。
Their life changed. Our lives changed. It was like a meteor hitting the earth when we met Brian.
她们的生活改变了。我们的生活也改变了。当我们遇见布莱恩时，就像一颗流星撞击地球。
Brian-- that was the hitchhiker's name, which I know because that guy's my dad. Cecilia-- that's my mom. And this story-- it's the story of how our family came to be, their legendary first meeting.
布莱恩——那是那个搭便车的人的名字，我知道这一点是因为那个人是我爸爸。塞西莉亚——那是我妈妈。而这个故事——就是我们家庭如何形成的传说，他们那传奇的第一次见面。
It was followed by a similarly legendary first date. My mom's sister and cousin dressed her up in their own clothes-- white bell bottoms, white platform heels. My dad showed up in a poncho, and he took her hiking in the redwood forest, where it rained.
随后是同样传奇的第一次约会。我妈妈的妹妹和表亲帮她打扮起来——白色喇叭裤，白色厚底高跟鞋。我爸爸穿着一件斗篷出现，带她去红木森林徒步，那天还下着雨。
He ended up carrying her so that she wouldn't ruin the shoes she'd borrowed. Two weeks later, they eloped, headed off to Reno, but ended up stopping in a random town nearby, where marriage licenses were $5 cheaper. They got married at 7:00 AM on Christmas Eve. Anita remembers them coming home after with their marriage license.
最后他背着她走，这样她就不会弄坏借来的鞋子。两周后，他们私奔了，本来打算去里诺，结果在一个附近的小镇停了下来，那里的结婚证便宜5美元。他们在圣诞前夜早上7点结婚了。安妮塔记得他们带着结婚证回来时的情景。
I can remember even the knock on the door. And I ran to open it, and there they were, standing there. I yelled to my mom that they were here, and she came running.
我甚至记得当时的敲门声。我跑去开门，他们就站在那里。我大声叫我妈妈说他们来了，她跑了过来。
Her mom, Manuelita.
也就是她的母亲，曼努埃利塔。
She welcomed them in, and I don't know what happened next, but they came back married. And they loved each other until the end.
她欢迎他们进来，我不知道接下来发生了什么，但他们回来时已经结婚了。他们相爱到生命尽头。
Wow. Yeah. That's so cool. It's like, it's such a good story.
哇。是的。太酷了。这真是一个很好的故事。
Like I said, legendary. This story is the bedrock foundation of how I see my parents, especially my dad. I picture him at 26, his misbuttoned shirt, catching rides through the West Coast alone.
就像我说的，传奇。这个故事是我们看待父母，尤其是看待我父亲的基石。我脑海中浮现出他26岁时的样子，衬衫扣子扣错，独自穿行在西海岸。
This big white guy from Detroit climbing into this car full of immigrants, just exuberant and thinking, wow, I'm going to marry this lady. And a picture of my mom at 26, having just arrived in the country, self-contained, determined, seeing this weirdo and deciding, yes. Him.
这个来自底特律的大个子白人挤进了一辆载满移民的车里，充满活力，心想：“哇，我要娶这位女士。”还有我妈妈26岁时的样子，刚到达这个国家，独立、坚定，看着这个怪人，决定道：“就是他。”
When you enter the family, this is pretty much the one story we make you memorize. And then you could be a citizen of the family. Here's my brother-in-law, Lars.
当你走进这个家庭，这基本上是必须背下来的故事。然后你就能成为这个家庭的一员。这是我的妹夫，拉斯。
How many times do you think you've heard this story?
你觉得你听过这个故事多少次了？
Oh, I don't know. Many times. 50, 100. [CHUCKLES] Many times.
噢，我不知道。很多次。50次，100次。（轻笑）很多次。
And the meaning of this story has always been clear.
而这个故事的意义一直很明确。
If they didn't pick him up, we would-- all of us wouldn't be here right now.
如果她们没有载他，我们……我们所有人现在都不会在这里了。
Here I am with my niece and nephews.
现在我和我的侄女、侄子们在一起。
I wouldn't be here, and you wouldn't be here. Your mom wouldn't be here.
我不会在这里，你也不会在这里。你妈妈也不会在这里。
And Sammy wouldn't be here.
萨米也不会在这里。
Sammy wouldn't be here.
萨米不会在这里。
Tia Nena wouldn't be here. Marian wouldn't be here. Wally wouldn't be here.
蒂亚·内娜不会在这里。玛丽安不会在这里。沃利不会在这里。
Anyone that we know wouldn't be here.
我们认识的任何人都不会在这里。
Wait, no!
等等，不！
Well, we wouldn't be here to know them.
好吧，我们不会在这里认识他们。
[KARL LAUGHS]
（卡尔笑声）
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
There's something predestined about it. This is such an important story, I thought. You know what? I want to visit the spot where the meteor struck.
这其中有些命中注定的意味。我想，这是一个如此重要的故事。你知道吗？我想去看看流星撞击的地方。
My dad died 10 years ago. I miss him, always. And he doesn't have a grave. He insisted on cremation by, quote, "the cheapest means possible."
我爸爸10年前去世了。我一直很想念他。他没有墓地。他坚持用火葬，引用他的话说，“用最便宜的方式”。
He didn't like fancy things. And I also think that he didn't want to be a burden. Anyway, what I want to remember him was not, like, a location I can go to. I can't, like, put flowers by a tombstone. So how about this place? This legendary spot where he climbed into a car and our family began. So, can't be hard. So where was it?
他不喜欢华丽的东西。而且我也觉得他不想成为负担。总之，我想纪念他的方式不是一个我可以去的地方。我不能像在墓碑旁献花那样。那这个地方怎么样？这个他爬进车里、我们的家庭开始的传奇之地。这应该不难吧。那么，它在哪里呢？
Anita says it was by the freeway exit by our house. Manuelita says it was an onramp heading downtown. But they're not definitive about it. So I went to the third person in the car that day, my mom. And she says, sure, I know exactly where it was. And then she starts to tell me this story.
安妮塔说是在我家旁边的高速出口。曼努埃利塔说是在通往市中心的匝道上。但她们都不确定。所以我去找了那天在车里的第三个人，我妈妈。她说：“当然，我清楚地记得在哪里。”然后她开始给我讲这个故事。
I remember. What I remember is that we were walking down the street, walking to the car. And Brian said, hola.
我记得。我记得我们当时走在街上，走向车子。布莱恩说了句“你好”。
Brian, my dad.
布莱恩，我爸爸。
And Manuelita said, hola, hola. We all say, hola.
曼努埃利塔说：“你好，你好。”我们也全都说：“你好。”
You saw him when he was walking?
你是说你看见他走在路上？
Yes. He was walking to go to the bus stop.
是的。他当时正步行去公交车站。
The bus stop? He was taking the bus? This is not the story I'd always heard. In my mom's version, they weren't in a car. She and Manuelita were walking down the street.
公交车站？他是坐公交车的？这和我一直听到的故事不一样。在我妈妈的版本里，她们没在车里。她和曼努埃利塔走在街上。
They had just left the Jacksons' house. The Jacksons were a family where my tia Manuelita worked as a cook. She says it was a beautiful day, not raining at all. And most importantly, dad wasn't hitchhiking.
她们刚离开杰克逊家。杰克逊一家是我姨妈曼努埃利塔做厨师的雇主。她说那天天气很好，一点也没下雨。最重要的是，爸爸当时并没有搭便车。
Was he, like, holding up a sign or something, saying he wanted a ride?
他当时是在举着牌子什么的，表示想要搭车吗？
No.
没有。
Because the story has always been hitchhiking.
因为故事一直说是搭便车。
No.
没有。
Wait, Mom, but your story and Anita's story is completely different. She remembers it clearly.
等等，妈妈，但你的故事和安妮塔的故事完全不同。她记得很清楚。
Your dad was walking to the stop.
你爸爸当时是在走去车站的路上。
But then why does she remember this other story?
但那她为什么记得另一个故事？
I don't know.
我不知道。
From my mom's point of view, this is especially mysterious because she's quite certain that Anita wasn't there. Not in a car, not on the street. Not there for this moment at all.
在我妈妈看来，这一点尤其神秘，因为她非常确定安妮塔当时不在场。不在车里，也不在街上。在那一刻根本不在。
I don't think Anita was.
我不认为安妮塔在场。
Anita remembers it.
安妮塔记得这件事。
I don't think she was. No. No, no.
我不认为她在。不，不，不。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
This kind of knocked me over. The hitchhiking story, as I've said, is the origin story of my family. My mom's had a private version of it for 50 years that she's kept herself during the many, many conversations where we tell it?
这简直让我大吃一惊。搭便车的故事，正如我所说，是我们家庭的起源故事。我妈妈50年来一直私下藏着另一个版本，在我们讲述这个故事的无数次谈话中，她都保持沉默？
When my dad died 10 years ago, we wrote about this story in his obituary. Like, printed it in our local newspaper. We ran that obituary by my mom. She didn't think it was worth correcting?
我爸爸10年前去世时，我们在他的讣告里写了这个故事。印在当地报纸上。我给我妈妈看了那份讣告。她觉得不值得纠正吗？
Dad was the memory keeper of our family, a big-hearted, big-brained guy who held on to everything that happened. Who had chicken pox first as a kid? Natalie, he'd say. What was the name of that iguana that we had that died? Mari-iguana, he'd say.
爸爸是我们家的记忆守护者，一个心胸开阔、头脑聪明的人，他记得发生的一切。小时候谁先得的水痘？“娜塔莉，”他会说。我们养的那只死掉的鬣蜥叫什么名字？“玛丽-鬣蜥（Mari-iguana），”他会说。
He would absolutely know exactly where this happened. And the thought that he's not here to tell us-- it makes him feel so gone, like we had a favorite photo of him, and we have no idea where it is anymore.
他绝对会清楚记得这件事发生在什么地方。一想到他不在了，不能告诉我们真相——这让他感觉真的很遥远，就像我们有一张关于他的最爱照片，却再也不知道它在哪儿了。
When my dad died, it was sudden, and it devastated me. As time passes, we've lost so much of him. His clothes have lost his smell of wool and sawdust and too much Tide laundry detergent.
爸爸去世时很突然，这摧毁了我。随着时间流逝，我们失去了他太多东西。他的衣服已经失去了那种羊毛、木屑和过量汰渍洗衣液的味道。
And this, it was like losing a big piece of him again, because in his absence and in our negligence, we simply forgot to remember. Unforgivable. I had to fix this. I had to get to the truth.
而这件事，就像再次失去了他很大一部分，因为在他缺席的情况下，由于我们的疏忽，我们只是忘记了如何记忆。不可饶恕。我必须解决这个问题。我必须找到真相。
I forced the three of them-- Manuelita, Anita, and my mom-- to sit down together to try to work this out, come to some agreement about what happened and where. Anita is stunned to hear that my mom and Manuelita don't think she was in the car.
我强迫她们三个——曼努埃利塔、安妮塔和我妈妈——坐在一起试图理清头绪，就发生的时间和地点达成一致。安妮塔听到我妈妈和曼努埃利塔认为她当时不在车里时感到震惊。
So yeah, my story is not going to change. I was in the car. I was in the front seat. You were in the back seat.
所以，是的，我的故事不会变。我在车里。我坐在前座。你坐在后座。
Mom turns to me.
妈妈转过来看着我。
I don't remember never Anita being around.
我不记得安妮塔在旁边过。
She tells the others they weren't even in a car.
她告诉其他人她们当时甚至不在车里。
But Manuelita, you remember him hitchhiking, and you were driving, and you pulled over, right?
但是曼努埃利塔，你记得他当时搭便车，是你开的车，你靠边停车了，对吧？
Yeah. Of course. That's why I picked him up.
是的。当然。所以我才接了他。
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
She remembers walking, that you all were walking.
她记得是在走路，你们都在走路。
No, we were not walking. Oh, yeah, I was driving. Yeah, I was driving. Yeah, hitchhiking. He was hitchhiking.
不，我们没在走路。噢，是的，我在开车。是的，我在开车。是的，搭便车。他在搭便车。
This went nowhere. And the fact that we've been telling this hitchhiking story for 50 years and my mom's never mentioned that she thinks it's complete bullshit? I have to say, that's very much like my mom. She's eminently capable of keeping her thoughts and feelings to herself.
这根本没进展。而我们讲这个搭便车的故事讲了50年，我妈妈从来没提到她认为这纯属胡扯？我必须说，这很像我妈妈。她非常善于把想法和感受藏在心里。
She has feelings, obviously.
很明显，她是有感情的。
But she shows love in concrete ways. An unasked-for plate of fruit, a bowl of soup. She'd give me her kidney or hide a body for me, no questions asked. But sitting around gabbing about feelings-- not her thing. She finds that trying. She'll either roll her eyes or blurt out something explosive and walk away or clam up. Here's us in the car.
但她用具体的方式表达爱。一份不请自来的水果盘，一碗汤。如果我要求，她会把肾捐给我，或者帮我藏尸体，什么都不会问。但围坐在一起闲聊情感——那不是她的风格。她觉得这很累人。她要么翻白眼，要么脱口而出什么爆炸性的言论然后走开，要么闭口不谈。这是我们在车里的情景。
Mom, so, but-- but-- I just-- is it interesting to you that you have one memory and other people have a different memory? Is it interesting?
妈妈，所以，但是……我只是……你有一个记忆，而其他人有不同的记忆，这对你来说有意思吗？这有意思吗？
Um, I know that stories are like that.
嗯，我知道故事就是这样。
I know, I know, but is it interesting? I want to talk about the feelings of it.
我知道，我知道，但这有意思吗？我想谈谈这件事背后的感受。
That's good. That's how we met.
那很好。我们就是这样相遇的。
Yeah, but what's it-- what's it like? How do you feel?
是啊，但这感觉是什么样的？你感觉如何？
Nothing. It's OK. [VEHICLE HONKING] Ay, ay, ay.
没什么。没关系。（汽车鸣笛声）唉，唉，唉。
She gets impatient. She dodges. In response, I get impatient with her, about everything. I compulsively nitpick everything she does.
她变得不耐烦了。她在回避。作为回应，我对她也变得不耐烦，对每件事都挑剔。
Can you put your bag in back? Because of the noise. It's too much noise.
你能把包放在后面吗？因为噪音。噪音太大了。
Yeah.
是的。
Rustling that bag makes noise that gets on the mic, I tell her. So does her beaded necklace.
我告诉她，翻动那个包产生的噪音会被麦克风收录。她戴的珠子项链也会。
Could you take off your necklace?
你能把项链摘了吗？
Yeah. [SPEAKS SPANISH]
好的。（用西班牙语交谈）
Rather than engage with me, she whips out her little pot of Mary Kay cold cream and starts stabbing it on her cheeks and forehead.
她没有配合我，而是掏出她那小盒玫琳凯冷霜，开始在脸颊和额头上抹。
Put some cream on my face. [SPEAKS SPANISH]
往脸上涂点霜。（用西班牙语交谈）
Mom, let's focus.
妈妈，我们专注点。
OK. I'm not going to-- OK.
好的。我不会——好的。
Can you just put the cream on after we go?
你能等我们走之后再涂霜吗？
OK.
好的。
But no--
但是没——
It's OK. Let's go now.
没关系。我们走吧。
You can't be messing with it as we drive.
你不能在我们开车的时候搞这个。
OK.
好的。
I'm a nightmare. She lets it go. She's a good mom. Of course, the day my parents met, there was one other person there-- my dad. I'd interviewed him in 2010, years before he died, before he even got sick.
我真是个噩梦。她放过了这件事。她是个好妈妈。当然，我父母相遇的那天，还有一个在场的人——我爸爸。我在2010年采访过他，在他去世前几年，在他生病之前。
I've never been able to bring myself to listen to that recording. Just too hard. So I had no memory of what we'd talked about that day. But I had a hunch that if I'd done an interview with him, I would have asked him to tell me this story.
我一直无法让自己去听那个录音。太难了。所以我对那天我们谈过什么毫无记忆。但我有一种预感，如果我对他做过采访，我肯定会要求他讲这个故事。
I had no idea where this interview was, but I'd given him a copy, and I knew he would have kept it. The week I talked to my mom, I spent hours digging through old file cabinets and boxes in the garage. I finally found it one night at 2:00 AM. I threw on all the lights, ran into bed, and listened immediately.
我不知道这份录音在哪儿，但我曾给他过一份拷贝，我知道他肯定留着。我和妈妈谈话后的那个星期，我花了几小时在车库里的旧档案柜和盒子里翻找。终于在某天凌晨2点找到了。我打开所有的灯，冲进床上，立刻听了起来。
OK. Um, how did you meet Mom?
好的。嗯，你是怎么遇见妈妈的？
I was hitchhiking on Rio Del Mar Boulevard. And Manuelita picked me up, and I believe Anita was in the car, too.
我当时在里奥德尔马大道（Rio Del Mar Boulevard）搭便车。曼努埃利塔载了我，我相信安妮塔也在车里。
Oh, my god. Of course he has all the answers.
噢，天哪。当然他掌握着所有答案。
Anita said, no, don't-- don't even think of stopping for this guy. And Manuelita said, he's cute! And, uh-- and that's how I met your mom.
安妮塔说：“不，别——想都别想，别停下来接这个人。”曼努埃利塔说：“他长得挺可爱！”然后……那就是我遇见你妈妈的过程。
What kind of car were they driving?
她们开的是什么车？
Huge. A Lincoln Continental. [CHUCKLES] Yeah, it was-- I mean, it was like a Star Wars machine, you know. The front of it went by, and then five minutes later, the rear of it went by. It was huge. Biggest car in the world. Manuelita, the smallest person in the world, is driving it.
巨大的那种。林肯大陆。（轻笑）是的，它……我的意思是，它就像一台《星球大战》里的机器，你知道吗？车头过去了，五分钟后，车尾才过去。太大了。世界上最巨大的车。曼努埃利塔，世界上个子最小的人，在开它。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Um, and what did you think when you got in the car?
嗯，当你上车时，你在想什么？
I said, um, she's a cutie.
我说，嗯，她是个小可爱。
That's the first thing you thought when you got in the car?
这是你上车后的第一个想法？
Of course. Yeah, yeah.
当然。是的，是的。
You weren't like, who are these tiny ladies picking up a huge-- [LAUGHS] like-- [LAUGHS]
你当时没想过，“这些小个子女士为什么要接一个巨大的……”（笑声）就像……（笑声）
I-- I didn't know. I didn't know what I was getting into.
我……我不知道。我不知道自己陷入了什么境地。
Oh. Why did you think she was cute?
噢。为什么你觉得她很可爱？
She was very self-confident and--
她很自信，而且……
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Well, you know your mom. She's nothing if not self-confident. Yeah. She's smart. Yeah, she's really smart. Really smart.
好吧，你了解你妈妈。她别的没有，就是自信。是的。她很聪明。是的，她真的很聪明。非常聪明。
So they picked you up on Rio Del Mar. In front of what? Like, what would be there today?
所以她们是在里奥德尔马上载你的。在什么前面？比如，今天那儿会是什么？
Same. It hasn't changed. Rio Del Mar. And right by that bridge-- you know the bridge on Rio Del Mar Boulevard?
一样。没变过。里奥德尔马。就在那座桥旁边……你认识里奥德尔马大道上的那座桥吗？
The one by, like--
那座靠近……比如……
The little bridge that goes across that little ravine there.
那座跨过那边小峡谷的小桥。
Oh, right there?
噢，就在那儿？
Yeah, right there. Uh-huh.
是的，就在那儿。嗯哼。
And so then what happened in the car? When did you get out?
然后车里发生了什么？你什么时候下车的？
They invited me over to dinner. Manuelita did. So I went over to dinner.
她们邀请我去吃晚餐。曼努埃利塔邀请的。所以我去吃了晚餐。
Anita was against this.
安妮塔是反对的。
Very much against this.
非常反对。
And then did you ask Mom out?
然后你约妈妈出去了吗？
Either that or Manuelita asked us both-- I think Manuelita asked us both out. She said, when are you-- when are you coming to take her out? Something like that.
要么是那样，要么是曼努埃利塔约我们俩出去——我想是曼努埃利塔约我们俩出去。她说：“你们什么时候出来约会？”之类的话。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
What did you say?
你是怎么说的？
I said, oh, I don't know. Tomorrow? She goes, OK.
我说，噢，我不知道。明天？她说，好吧。
This recording is from 14 years ago. I haven't really heard his voice in 10 years, since he died. I hadn't forgotten, but I sort of had forgotten, how much fun we had just talking to each other.
这段录音是14年前的。他去世10年后，我就再也没怎么听过他的声音了。我并没有忘记，但我确实有点淡忘了，我们俩聊天时曾经有多开心。
And my dad told the same story as Anita and Manuelita. This story my dad tells about their meeting was not news to my mom. She says, yeah, we always disagreed about that. Of course he said that. He's got it wrong. Always has.
我爸爸讲的故事版本和安妮塔以及曼努埃利塔讲的一样。我爸爸讲的关于他们初次相遇的故事对我妈妈来说并不是什么新闻。她说：“是啊，我们一直在这个问题上意见不合。他当然会那样说。他记错了。一直都记错了。”
I remember we argued a lot when we told people how we met. People laughed because he wants to say one thing, I want to say another thing.
我记得当我们告诉别人我们是怎么认识的时候，我们吵了很多架。大家听了都笑，因为他坚持要说一种版本，我想说另一种。
I thought a lot about why my mom prefers her version, where he's walking to a bus stop and not hitchhiking. And the main thing I keep thinking about is, in my dad's version, my mom's people make the first move. Their meeting is kind of random, a split-second fluke.
我想了很多关于为什么我妈妈更喜欢她的那个版本，就是他当时走在去公交车站的路上，而不是搭便车。我一直在想的最主要的一点是，在我爸爸的版本里，是我妈妈那边的人采取了主动。他们的相遇是一种随机的、电光火石的巧合。
But in the version my mom likes, everyone's on foot, on this rainless, beautiful day, and my dad sees them and approaches. He makes the first move, which is maybe more romantic. Everyone wants to be chosen. I run my hypothesis by her. She kind of blinks at me blankly, slightly impatient. Nothing.
但在妈妈喜欢的版本里，大家都在步行，在一个没有雨、风景优美的日子里，我爸爸看见了她们并主动接近。他采取了主动，这也许更浪漫。每个人都想成为被选择的那一个。我把我的假说告诉她。她茫然地看着我，有些不耐烦。什么也没说。
The day after I found that interview with my dad, I woke up early. And the mismatched memories-- it all started clicking together.
找到我爸爸那个采访的第二天，我起得很早。那些不匹配的记忆——一切开始串联起来了。
OK, this is just me in my room. It's Wednesday. [CLEARS THROAT] Last night, I listened to that recording, and Dad said it was in Rio Del Mar, right by the bridge. So I think-- I think I just figured it out.
好的，这只是我在房间里。现在是周三。（清嗓子）昨晚，我听了那个录音，爸爸说是在里奥德尔马，就在桥旁边。所以我想……我想我刚才理清了。
I think their car was parked on the street a little ways from the Jacksons' house, and they had to walk to the car from the house. So my mom remembers that walk. And then they got in and had just started driving when they hit that bridge and saw my dad.
我想她们的车当时停在杰克逊家稍微远一点的街道上，她们必须从房子走到车旁。所以我妈妈记得那段路程。然后她们上车，刚开始驾驶就到了那座桥，看见了我爸爸。
That's, like, a block away from the Jacksons'. No time at all. Easy for my mom to forget. And there he stood, not at a bus stop, but hitchhiking. OK, here's me explaining my theory to my mom.
那离杰克逊家也就一个街区远。用不了多少时间。我妈妈很容易就会忘记。他就站在那里，不是在公交车站，而是在搭便车。好了，这里是我在向妈妈解释我的理论。
And you had barely gotten in the car. You went around the corner, and Dad was right there.
你们刚上车，拐了个弯，爸爸就在那儿。
Mm-hmm. We drove around the corner?
嗯哼。我们拐了个弯？
Maybe. Because what Dad said-- and Dad has a really good memory, you know.
可能吧。因为爸爸说的话——爸爸的记性真的很好，你知道的。
Oh, yeah, I know. [LAUGHS]
噢，是的，我知道。（笑声）
But what I think might have happened is-- Mom, your feet. Can you stop?
但我认为可能发生的是——妈妈，你的脚。能停下来吗？
Yeah.
好的。
I think you guys might have just gotten in the car, barely driven, and then he was right there.
我想你们可能刚上车，没开多远，他就刚好在那儿。
Yeah, I think so. I think that's what it is.
是的，我想是这样。我想就是这样。
Do you think that sounds right?
你觉得听起来对吗？
Mm-hmm. I think it sounds right. Yeah, that's how I remember. Not much driving.
嗯哼。听起来是对的。是的，我记得就是这样。没怎么开车。
Yeah. Do you want to go drive and see where he said? Let's go look at--
是啊。你想开车去看看他说的那个地方吗？让我们去看看——
Sure. [SPEAKS SPANISH] We are close by. Yeah.
好啊。（用西班牙语交谈）我们离得很近。是的。
We drive to the spot my dad said. You remember.
我们开车去了爸爸说的地方。你记得。
Rio Del Mar and right by that bridge. The little bridge that goes across that little ravine.
里奥德尔马，就在那座桥旁边。跨过那个小峡谷的小桥。
The Jackson house is maybe a minute away, around the corner. There are trees everywhere, an intersection between residential blocks. Not much around, except for--
杰克逊家大概在离这儿一分钟路程的地方，拐个弯就到了。到处都是树，那是住宅区之间的路口。周围没太多东西，除了——
This bus stop. He was walking here.
这个公交车站。他当时正走在这儿。
Mom, it's a bus stop!
妈妈，这是一个公交车站！
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I've never seen this bus stop before.
我以前从来没见过这个公交车站。
She had been talking about this bus stop the whole time, and I didn't believe her.
她一直都在说这个公交车站，而我不相信她。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Mom, it's the bus stop! The one you've been talking about.
妈妈，就是这个车站！你一直说的那一个。
Yeah. But he was walking to the bus stop.
是的。但他当时正走去这个公交车站。
I think this is it, Mom.
我想就是这儿了，妈妈。
Oh, I'm so glad. Yeah.
噢，我太高兴了。是的。
I knew this road like the back of my hand, and I'd never seen a bus stop there. But here it was, tucked under some trees, just a sign and a little bench.
我对这条路熟悉得像自己的手心一样，但我从来没看到那儿有个公交车站。但它确实就在这儿，隐藏在几棵树下，只有一个牌子和一张小长凳。
Mom, good job. [LAUGHS]
妈妈，干得好。（笑声）
Well, the past memory never goes away, they say.
好吧，人们常说，过去的记忆永远不会消失。
I'm so relieved.
我感到如释重负。
[LAUGHS] Yeah. Very close. Everything is so close. We found the bus stop.
（笑声）是的。非常近。一切都离得这么近。我们找到了那个公交车站。
[SIGHS] Wow.
（叹气）哇。
This was it, what I'd wanted to find, the place our family began, a bus stop I'd driven past a million times. Not the fanciest spot in the world, but pretty, a place you wouldn't mind visiting again.
这就是我一直想找的地方，我们家开始的地方，一个我开车路过一百万次的公交车站。虽然不是世界上最华丽的地方，但很漂亮，一个你愿意再次光临的地方。
My mom said next time I'm in town, we should go sit at that bus stop, bring champagne, toast my dad. Probably get a ticket, she said. But to hell with it.
我妈妈说下次我回城里，我们应该去那个车站坐坐，带上香槟，为我爸爸干杯。她说大概会收到罚单，但去他妈的吧。
Part of what made this whole project a little weird for me was this thing that I've mentioned a few times, that my mom doesn't really like discussing feelings. But I learned something, talking to my sister Kim about all this stuff, that driving home, I really wanted to tell my mom.
整个项目让我觉得有点奇怪的部分原因，是我提到过几次的事实——我妈妈不太喜欢谈论感受。但在和我妹妹金谈论这些事情时，我学到了一些东西，回家的路上，我真的很想告诉妈妈。
Do you know that when he was sick, Manuelita came to the house and she was sitting with him.
你知道吗，在他病重的时候，曼努埃利塔去过家里陪他坐着。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
And, um-- and he was sick, you know. He was just lying down and not really talking that much at that point. But he did say to her, he said, Manuelita, thank you for my life.
而且……他当时病得很重，你知道。那时候他只是躺着，没怎么说话。但他确实对她说：“曼努埃利塔，谢谢你给我的一切。”
Hmm.
嗯。
Did you know that?
你知道这件事吗？
He said-- I don't remember. I think he said something, yeah.
他说……我不记得了。我想他说过什么，是的。
What, um-- what does it feel like to hear that he said that?
什么……听到他那么说，你感觉如何？
It's nice.
很好。
Tell me more. Tell me more about what it feels like.
告诉我更多。再多跟我说说那是什么感觉。
What I feel like-- I feel like crying.
我的感觉是……我想哭。
What?
什么？
(CRYING) Like crying.
（哭泣）想哭。
You feel like crying?
你想哭吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[CRYING]
（哭泣）
If I had known that he was going to die so fast, so soon.
如果我早知道他会走得这么快，这么突然的话。
Well, I think, when I hear that story, it's kind of beautiful to me, because he loved his life so much.
嗯，我想，当我听到那个故事时，我觉得它很美，因为他那么热爱他的生命。
He loved it, yeah.
他很热爱它，是的。
And he loved his family, and he loved you.
而且他爱他的家人，也爱你。
Mm, yeah. Yeah.
嗯，是的。是的。
Right?
对吧？
Mm-hmm. He said thanks to me, too. And you know, we're not perfect, but we can forgive if we have hurt-- if we-- when he was dying.
嗯哼。他也对我说过谢谢。你知道，我们不完美，但如果我们要伤害……如果我们……在他弥留之际，我们是可以原谅对方的。
I brought up my dad's last days, and my mom's mind went straight to their last night together. Cut to the heart of her grief, to this moment when he was dying and they forgave each other for their hurts. We've never talked about this. My mom never talks like this.
我提到了爸爸最后的日子，妈妈的心思直接回到了他们在一起的最后一晚。切入了她悲伤的核心，在那一刻，当他垂死之际，他们原谅了彼此曾经造成的伤害。我们从没谈过这个。我妈妈从来不会这样说话。
You know, he said, the number one thing-- that everything was in order, and I forgive him, whatever he did. Because we're not perfect, and he forgave me, too, whatever I did. So we talked in the room, you know, at the end?
你知道，他说，最重要的一点——一切都交代好了，无论他做了什么，我都原谅他。因为我们不完美，无论我做了什么，他也原谅了我。所以我们在房间里谈了，你知道，在最后时刻？
Yeah.
是的。
And then we hugged, and I'm so glad we sleep together the last night. But I was so afraid to touch him. I didn't want to hurt him. So I just touched his legs and his feet, and he slept the whole night. No problem.
然后我们拥抱了，我很高兴我们最后一晚睡在一起。但我很怕触碰他。我不想弄疼他。所以我只是摸了摸他的腿和脚，他就那样睡了一整晚。没问题。
Mom didn't stop there. She told me something else. When I was nine, my parents hit a rough patch in their relationship and decided to separate.
妈妈没停在那儿。她还告诉了我另一件事。我九岁时，父母的关系出现过一段摩擦，决定分开。
After a few months, they got back together. I never really knew how or why. We didn't like to speak about that time in my family. But as I was talking to my mom about all this, she brought it up.
几个月后，他们复合了。我从没真正了解是如何或为什么复合的。在我们家，我们不喜欢谈论那段时间。但在我和妈妈谈论所有这些事时，她提到了。
You want to know the real hitchhiking story, she said. And she told me that during the time they were separated, one day, she was driving down the street, and she saw my dad was walking. And as she approached him on the road, he saw it was her in her Volvo, and he threw his thumb in the air. Cool joke, huh?
她说，你想知道真正的搭便车故事吗。她告诉我，在他们分开的那段时间里，有一天，她开车上街，看到我爸爸在走路。当她在路上靠近他时，他看到是她开着沃尔沃，就顺势竖起了大拇指，搭便车。酷炫的玩笑吧？
So she stopped, picked him up. A couple of days later, they got back together. That's the important story, she said. After that, my parents stayed married another 20 years.
于是她停下车，载了他。几天后，他们复合了。她说，那才是重要的故事。那之后，我父母又保持了20年的婚姻。
During that time, they had a blast together, sometimes inseparable. The best time of their marriage, my mom tells me, after they returned to that root moment where everything started. Only this time, it wasn't random chance. It was his choice to flag her down and hers to scoop him up.
在那段时间里，他们玩得很开心，有时形影不离。我妈妈告诉我，他们婚姻中最美好的时光，是在他们回到那一切开始的根源之后。只是这一次，这不是偶然的机会。是他选择向她招手，而她选择接他上车。
Lilly Sullivan is a producer on our show. Special thanks to Lilly's sisters. This song is one of their dad's favorites. He used to play it for them on the piano when they were growing up.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制片人。特别感谢莉莉的姐妹们。这首歌是她们父亲最爱的歌曲之一。在她们成长过程中，他常为她们弹奏这首歌。
["YOU AIN'T GOIN' NOWHERE" BY BOB DYLAN]
（鲍勃·迪伦演唱《你哪儿也去不了》）
Coming up, one badly tuned instrument on one song at one concert can change your life. That's in a minute, on Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，在一场音乐会上，一首曲子里的一件音准错误的乐器，就能改变你的人生。一分钟后，在芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "If You Want to Destroy My Sweater, Hold This Thread As I Walk Away." We have stories about small moments between people that suddenly change how everything looks. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, What's With These Homies Dissing My Girl?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“如果你想毁了我的毛衣，在我走开时扯住这根线”。我们讲述了一些人们之间的小时刻，这些时刻突然改变了一切的面貌。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，那帮诋毁我女孩的哥们儿怎么了？
In his early 20s, Mike Comite wanted to be a professional musician. He was trying his absolute hardest to make that happen, until one day, it all came undone-- weirdly, right in front of Weezer. Mike tells what happened.
20岁出头时，迈克·科米特想成为一名专业音乐人。他竭尽全力去实现这个目标，直到有一天，一切都落空了——不可思议的是，就在威瑟乐队面前。迈克讲述了发生的事情。
There's this video. I've watched it more times than I'd like to admit in the last decade and a half, kind of like a retired football player watching old game tapes from his glory days, who pauses and rewinds that one play where he tore his ACL over and over to see where his career went sideways. It happened at Bonnaroo, this music festival with some of the biggest acts in the world.
有一段视频。在过去十五年里，我看过它的次数多到我自己都不敢承认，就像一个退役橄榄球运动员一遍遍观看他光辉岁月的旧比赛录像，不断暂停并倒带那个让他十字韧带撕裂的关键动作，试图寻找他职业生涯走向弯路的地方。这发生在波纳罗（Bonnaroo）音乐节上，这是一个汇集了世界上最顶尖艺人的音乐节。
That year, Dave Matthews Band and Jay-Z were playing. It was 2010. The band I was in was invited to play on one of the medium-sized stages, which was a huge deal for us. There'd be over 2,000 people watching. It'd be the biggest stage we'd ever played on.
那年，戴夫·马修斯乐队（Dave Matthews Band）和Jay-Z都在演出。那是2010年。我所在的乐队受邀在其中一个中型舞台表演，这对我们来说是件大事。现场会有超过2000名观众观看，这将是我们参与过的最大舞台。
But then, I saw that Weezer was also playing Bonnaroo. It felt like some kind of fated opportunity. We were actually covering a Weezer song in our set, and so I had this big idea.
但后来，我发现威瑟乐队也在波纳罗演出。这感觉像是一种注定的机会。我们其实在翻唱一首威瑟的歌，于是我有个大胆的想法。
Our front person, Julia, was a musician who had blown up on YouTube. She had thousands of followers on social media. What if we got them all to tweet at Weezer's lead singer, Rivers Cuomo, to see if he'd come sing with us? I asked Julia, and she was game for it, and shockingly, it worked, better than we could have hoped.
我们的主唱朱莉娅是一位在YouTube上走红的音乐人。她在社交媒体上有成千上万的粉丝。如果我们能让他们所有人都发推文给威瑟的主唱里弗斯·科莫（Rivers Cuomo），看看他会不会来和我们一起唱歌呢？我问了朱莉娅，她对此很有兴趣，令人震惊的是，它起效了，效果比我们期望的还要好。
Rivers didn't come sing with us. Instead, he invited Julia to come play her ukulele and sing with Weezer during one of their songs on the main stage. Julia's visibility at Bonnaroo would be multiplied tenfold. If this went well, who knows where it could lead? Maybe Weezer would bring us on tour with them as their opener.
里弗斯没有来和我们一起唱歌。相反，他邀请朱莉娅去主舞台，在他们的一首歌中用尤克里里伴奏并合唱。朱莉娅在波纳罗的曝光率将翻上十倍。如果这次表现好，谁知道会带来什么后果呢？也许威瑟会带我们去巡演做他们的暖场嘉宾。
Our agent immediately submitted us to their team for some of their upcoming shows. Or maybe Rivers would write a song with Julia, play on our record, or she'd play on theirs. The possibilities kept me up at night.
我们的经纪人立刻帮我们向他们的团队提交了后续的一些演出申请。或者也许里弗斯会和朱莉娅写首歌，在我们的专辑里演奏，或者朱莉娅在他们的专辑里演奏。这些可能性让我彻夜难眠。
I was 22. I'd only been playing music professionally for a year at that point. But I was convinced this would be the moment that would transform our careers. The day of the show, Julia split off from our group to rehearse with Weezer on their tour bus. I felt a little sting finding out I wasn't going to meet them, too.
那时我22岁。到那时为止，我从事专业音乐工作才一年。但我确信这将是转变我们职业生涯的时刻。演出当天，朱莉娅离开我们小组，去威瑟的巡演大巴上彩排。得知自己没能见到他们，我感到有一点点刺痛。
Weezer went on a little before sunset. Me and the rest of the band sat way back in the crowd on some bleachers, while Julia was somewhere backstage. There had to be at least 20,000 people between us and Weezer.
威瑟在日落前不久登台。我和乐队其他成员坐在离舞台很远的人群后面的一排看台上，而朱莉娅在后台的某个地方。在我们和威瑟之间肯定至少有20000人。
I couldn't believe that a dumb idea I'd cooked up in rehearsal had led to this. The song Julia was going to play on was called "Tripping Down the Freeway." Weezer started it a few songs into their set.
我简直不敢相信我在排练时想出的一个愚蠢主意竟然会导致现在这样的局面。朱莉娅要参加的那首歌叫《在高速公路上漫游》（Tripping Down the Freeway）。威瑟在演出进行了几首歌之后开始了这首歌。
Here's a new song called, "Tripping Down the Freeway."
这是一首新歌，叫《在高速公路上漫游》。
[CROWD CHEERING]
（人群欢呼）
Julia is off stage for the first half of the song. But after the guitar solo, Rivers brings the band down to a vamp and has Julia come out kind of dramatically.
朱莉娅在歌曲前半部分没在台上。但在吉他独奏之后，里弗斯让乐队减弱节奏，让朱莉娅以一种戏剧性的方式出场。
All right. We're going to bring out a special guest now! Bonnaroo, this is Julia Nunes on ukulele.
好了。现在我们要请出一位特别嘉宾！波纳罗，这是弹尤克里里的朱莉娅·努内斯。
Julia walks on stage, strumming her uke, but something sounds off.
朱莉娅走上舞台，拨动她的尤克里里，但听起来不对劲。
Are we in the right tuning?
我们的音准对吗？
They are not in the right tuning. She's in a different key.
她们的调子不对。她处在一个不同的音调里。
Oh, it's supposed to be E-flat.
噢，应该是降E调。
For a split second, I'm convinced I'm having a nightmare. I try telling myself to wake up.
在那一瞬间，我确信我是在做噩梦。我努力告诉自己醒过来。
She's got this amazing tuner on her ukulele. We'll get it straightened out right now.
她的尤克里里上有一个很棒的调音器。我们现在就把音准调好。
Nope. Weezer is still on stage, having a conversation mid-song about Julia's tuning through the PA system. Rivers pivots.
没调好。威瑟还在舞台上，通过扩音系统，在演出中途讨论着朱莉娅的调音问题。里弗斯转换了方向。
All right. I'm going to tell a little story while you tune your ukulele.
好吧。我来讲个小故事，你们去调尤克里里的音。
He turns to the crowd and starts talking about how Julia had ended up on stage with him that day, about Twitter, about Julia's fans.
他转向观众，开始谈论朱莉娅今天是怎么上台的，谈论推特，谈论朱莉娅的粉丝。
They started to hit me up, saying, hey, dawwwg, Julia's an amazing singer and ukuleleist. Most of the time, she even knows what key the song is in, so why don't you guys have her up?
他们开始联系我，说：“嘿，老兄，朱莉娅是一个出色的歌手和尤克里里手。大多数时候，她甚至知道歌的音调，为什么你们不让她上来呢？”
He's making fun of her? I start clenching my jaw from the stands.
他在取笑她吗？我坐在看台上，咬紧了牙关。
I said, I don't know, man! This is Weezer. This is a professional act. We demand perfection. And Julia's fans said, trust us, dawg. Julia's the bomb!
我说：“我不知道，伙计！这是威瑟。这是专业演出。我们要求完美。”朱莉娅的粉丝说：“相信我们，老兄。朱莉娅太棒了！”
I'm mortified. I can't believe how mean he's being to her. Just so passive-aggressive. At this point, our crew member who's been sitting next to me, excitedly filming Julia's big moment, quietly stops recording and puts down her camera. This isn't her video. Someone else posted this one on YouTube.
我感到羞愧难当。我无法相信他竟对她这么刻薄。简直太消极进攻了。就在此时，坐在我旁边兴奋地拍摄朱莉娅大场面的我们团队成员，悄悄停止了录制，放下了相机。这不是她的视频。这段视频是别人上传到YouTube上的。
I couldn't help thinking, I'd been the one to suggest she do this in the first place. This was on me. After an excruciating 62 seconds of improv, Rivers wanders across the stage to where Julia is trying to retune with another band member.
我忍不住想，当初是我建议她这么做的。这事怪我。在经历了一段痛苦的62秒即兴表演后，里弗斯走过舞台，来到正在和其他乐队成员试图重新调音的朱莉娅身边。
So, uh, we could just have you sing.
所以，呃，我们可以让你直接唱。
I'm just going to sing.
我就直接唱好了。
I'm just going to sing, she says.
我就直接唱，她说。
All right. She's just going to sing. Check your mic.
好了。她就直接唱。检查一下麦克风。
Oh, what the hell.
噢，管它呢。
[YELLS]
（大喊）
Yeah!
耶！
[CROWD CHEERING]
（人群欢呼）
Yeah!
耶！
All right, give us the bass line, Scott.
好了，斯科特，给我们一段低音线。
Rivers counts off and starts singing, and Julia jumps in.
里弗斯开始打拍子并唱歌，朱莉娅跟了进来。
1, 2, 3. (SINGING) No way. We ain't going to break up. We made a promise, and our will won't fade out.
1，2，3。（唱歌）没门。我们不会分手。我们许下过诺言，我们的意志不会消散。
Julia looks so small from where we're sitting. But I can tell she's holding her ukulele by her side as she sings. They finish the song. Rivers thanks Julia, and she walks off the stage. I'm sitting in the bleachers, shocked by what just happened. Weezer keeps playing a bunch of my favorite songs, and I can't enjoy them.
从我们的位置看过去，朱莉娅显得那么渺小。但我能看出她在唱歌时把尤克里里拿在身侧。他们结束了这首歌。里弗斯感谢了朱莉娅，她走下了舞台。我坐在看台上，被刚才发生的事震住了。威瑟继续唱了几首我最爱的歌，但我再也无法享受了。
Give me the guitar, my man.
把吉他给我，伙计。
The next day, Rivers tweeted at Julia and thanked her for playing despite the mishap. A few weeks later, Weezer's manager officially turned us down for the opening spot on tour.
第二天，里弗斯在推特上感谢了朱莉娅，尽管发生了那次失误，仍感谢她参与演出。几周后，威瑟的经纪人正式回绝了我们担任他们巡演暖场嘉宾的请求。
In the music business, you need some moment to pull you out of obscurity and propel you forward. And it felt like, for us, Weezer had been it. Instead, we'd blown it. And that was the beginning of the end.
在音乐行业，你需要一个时刻来把你从籍籍无名中拉出来，推动你前进。我本以为，对我们来说，威瑟就是那个时刻。相反，我们搞砸了。那成了终结的开始。
After Bonnaroo, Julia and I stayed busy touring, just the two of us, for a while. But then things slowed down. Julia and her management were about to part ways. I started getting nervous about being able to support myself, so I tapped out of touring with Julia and got a full-time job where a lot of struggling musicians and actors end up-- at the Apple Store.
波纳罗之后，朱莉娅和我忙着巡演，有一段时间只有我们俩。但后来情况慢了下来。朱莉娅和她的经纪公司即将分道扬镳。我开始担心能不能养活自己，于是我退出了和朱莉娅的巡演，找了一份许多苦苦挣扎的音乐人和演员最终会去的工作——在苹果店上班。
And so this is when I started watching and rewatching that video, the Weezer performance. I've been doing that for the last 14 years. Each replay, I keep hoping that it won't be as bad as I remember, but it always is. I'm still stuck on, what the fuck happened? And in particular, was it our fault?
于是我开始不断地观看那段视频，也就是威瑟的那次演出。在过去的14年里，我一直这么做。每一次重播，我都希望它不会像我记忆中那么糟糕，但总是如此。我仍然纠结于：到底发生了什么？尤其是，这是我们的错吗？
On stage, Rivers had made it seem like it. But I've gone through the details again and again. Julia had received tuning instructions from Weezer's road manager. Were those incorrect?
在舞台上，里弗斯把它表现得好像是我们的错。但我一次又一次地核对细节。朱莉娅收到了威瑟公路经纪人的调音说明。那些说明是错误的吗？
Had Julia done the math wrong tuning her uke? Had I? I'd helped her with that. I found a video of Julia rehearsing with Weezer on their tour bus. She was in the wrong tuning there, too, but no one had noticed?
朱莉娅算错了尤克里里的调音吗？我算错了吗？我帮过她。我找到了一段朱莉娅在威瑟巡演大巴上排练的视频。她在那里也是用的错误的调音，但没人注意到？
Julia might know what went wrong, but I never really talked to her about that show. Only once, right after. It was uncomfortable. She was clearly upset, had been crying. She asked to let it go, so I did. But she must remember something from that day. So I called her.
朱莉娅可能知道出了什么问题，但我从来没跟她谈过那场演出。只有一次，就在事后不久。那次谈话让人不舒服。她显然很沮丧，一直在哭。她要求我别再提了，我就照做了。但她一定记得那天的一些事情。所以我给她打了电话。
When is the last time you thought about the Weezer performance?
你上次想到威瑟那次演出是什么时候？
It doesn't, like, revisit me in the quiet, dark night.
它并不会在安静黑暗的夜晚再次造访我。
OK.
好的。
I think, when Weezer comes up, like if Weezer is on at a party, I might or might not be like, I've played with Weezer once, and I totally-- [LAUGHS] fumbled.
我想，当威瑟被提到时，比如如果在聚会上放威瑟的歌，我可能会，也可能不会说：“我曾经和威瑟同台演出过，而且我完全……（笑声）搞砸了。”
Julia lives in Austin, Texas now. She's still releasing music, but her career has shifted more towards life coaching and guided meditation. Her memories of the Weezer incident were not as vivid as mine.
朱莉娅现在住在德克萨斯州奥斯汀。她仍在发布音乐，但她的职业生涯更多转向了生活指导和引导式冥想。她对威瑟事件的记忆不像我那么生动。
She didn't remember how she and Weezer got in touch. She didn't remember what year it happened. She definitely did not have the email from the road manager about the tuning, and she never puzzled over why her tuning was off. Because for her, that whole show was a totally different experience. When Rivers was saying all that stuff about her on stage--
她不记得她和威瑟是怎么建立联系的。她不记得是哪一年发生的。她肯定没有留着公路经纪人关于调音的邮件，她也从来没纠结过为什么音准会跑调。因为对她来说，整场演出是一次完全不同的体验。当里弗斯在台上说那些关于她的事情时——
It never registered to me as, like, anything-- anything other than a musician just trying to make the show go.
我从来没觉得那意味着什么……除了一个音乐人只是想让演出顺利进行而已。
Oh, my god, I feel like I've just been stewing in it for so long, being like, that dude was an asshole to my friend.
噢，天哪，我觉得我一直沉浸在里面太久了，一直觉得那家伙对我朋友是个混蛋。
Oh, Mike! No way, man. I have never once thought that Rivers was mean. I didn't know what to say in that moment. I didn't know what to do. Like, he could have just been like, OK, never mind.
噢，迈克！不是那样的，伙计。我从来没觉得里弗斯刻薄过。那一刻我不知道该说什么。我不知道该做什么。他本来完全可以像说“好的，没关系”那样处理的。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
But the fact that he came up with a real-time solution to be like, yeah, just sing-- I was so grateful.
但事实是他提出了一个实时的解决方案，说“是的，你就直接唱吧”——我非常感激。
I watch this video probably more often than I should. [CHUCKLES] I feel like I'm responsible for it in a way that's like, if I had just not said anything in that rehearsal that day, we could have just gone about our days and rehearsed and then just had our set at Bonnaroo. And then you would have come to the Weezer set and sat in the bleachers with us, and we just would have enjoyed Weezer together.
我观看这段视频的次数可能比我应该看的还要多。（轻笑）我觉得我以一种方式对此负有责任，就像是，如果那天我在排练时什么都没说，我们本可以过好各自的日子，进行排练，然后在波纳罗有我们自己的演出。然后你本可以来看威瑟的演出，和我们一起坐在看台上，我们本可以一起享受威瑟的演出。
[GASPS] Mike, don't you dare.
（惊呼）迈克，你敢！
But instead, you went on stage with him, and this thing that could have changed your career, in my view, had this effect that, you seemed so sad afterwards and devastated. And I was like, oh, my god, if I had just said nothing, this wouldn't have happened to you.
但相反，你和他上了台，而这件本来可能改变你职业生涯的事情，在我看来，却产生了这样的后果，你事后看起来那么悲伤和绝望。我当时心想，噢天哪，如果我当时什么都不说，这一切就不会发生在你身上了。
God, I-- I don't think that experience had any sort of detrimental pivot for my career. The thing that made my career not happen is that I couldn't take the pressure. It's not that you-- I think that you offering that Weezer thing was brilliant. I wish I would have done a bunch of different things, but not playing with Weezer and not fucking up on stage is not one of my regrets at all.
天哪，我……我不认为那次经历对我的职业生涯有什么负面的转折。让我的事业没能发展下去的原因是我无法承受压力。并不是因为你……我认为你提出那个威瑟的机会是天才的举动。我希望我能做很多不同的事情，但没有和威瑟一起演奏或者没有在舞台上搞砸，并不在我的遗憾清单里。
[CHUCKLES] I'm glad. [SIGHS IN RELIEF]
（轻笑）我很高兴。（如释重负的叹气）
[JULIA LAUGHS]
（朱莉娅笑声）
Julia was so much more at peace with the day than I was. She said the band, our band, wasn't sounding good to her anyways. She thought opening for Weezer was a long shot, even if she had been in the right tuning for "Tripping Down the Freeway."
朱莉娅对那天的事情比我坦然得多。她说反正我们的乐队对她来说听起来也不太好。她认为即使她在《在高速公路上漫游》时调音正确，能给威瑟做暖场也是一件小概率事件。
But also, the moment Julia remembered most from that performance wasn't the mistake. It was the part of the video that I usually skip over, the moment where it works out, after Rivers asked Julia if she wants to sing.
但同样，朱莉娅对那场演出记忆最深刻的时刻并不是那个错误。那是视频中我通常会跳过去的部分，也就是事情变得顺利的部分，在里弗斯问朱莉娅她是否想唱歌之后。
I'm looking Rivers Cuomo in the eye. Once we decide to start singing, everyone cheers. And we start, like, dancing together, and we put our arms around each other, and we're, like, head to head, singing, like, full blast, "Tripping Down the Freeway." And I felt like we sounded really good together. Yeah, I don't know. Like, all of that feels important to me.
我看着里弗斯·科莫的眼睛。当我们决定开始唱歌时，每个人都在欢呼。我们开始像是一起跳舞，我们搂着彼此，我们头挨着头，全心全意地合唱《在高速公路上漫游》。我觉得我们听起来配合得真不错。是的，我不知道。总之，所有这些对我来说都很有意义。
You can't see any of this in the video I'd been replaying all these years. That one was shot from way back near the bleachers, where I watched the show. I almost couldn't believe what Julia described. But changing up the wording of my YouTube search, I found another video from that day, filmed close to the stage.
在我多年来重播的那个视频里，你看不到任何这些画面。那是从靠近看台的远处拍摄的，我就是在那儿看的演出。我几乎不敢相信朱莉娅描述的内容。但改了下YouTube搜索词后，我找到了那天拍摄的另一段视频，是从靠近舞台的地方拍的。
You can see everyone's faces, and even when the tuning mistake becomes apparent, they're smiling and they're laughing. Julia and Rivers dance. They're having a great time.
你能看到每个人的脸，即使当调音错误显现出来时，他们也在微笑和欢笑。朱莉娅和里弗斯在跳舞。他们玩得很开心。
Watching it, I felt this wave of relief. It's what I was missing all these years. Julia was OK, and I believed her that the band didn't break up because of a tuning mistake. And this moment wasn't why I stopped playing music for a living.
看着它，我感受到一阵释怀。这正是我多年来缺失的东西。朱莉娅没事，我相信她，乐队并不是因为调音错误而解散的。而这一时刻也不是我停止以音乐为生的原因。
After Julia and I talked, I finally heard back from Weezer's former road manager. She found the email they'd sent us before the performance, and the instructions were wrong. There would have been no way for Julia and me to tune correctly with them. I had the full answer now, but I was surprised by how little it mattered to me. I was over it.
在我和朱莉娅谈过之后，我终于得到了威瑟前公路经纪人的回复。她找到了他们在演出前发给我们的邮件，上面的说明是错的。朱莉娅和我根本不可能用正确的音调和他们配合。我现在有了完整的答案，但我惊讶于它对我来说已经没那么重要了。我已经走出来了。
Mike Comite. He is one of the super skilled people who work here at the show, doing audio mixes and adding music to our stories. Diane Wu produced this story. Here is Mike playing guitar and singing with Julia, whose full name, by the way, is Julia Nunes. This is a song they used to cover together, years ago.
迈克·科米特。他是我们节目组超级能干的工作人员之一，负责音频混音并为我们的故事添加音乐。戴安·吴制作了这个故事。这是迈克在弹吉他并与朱莉娅合唱，顺便说一下，她的全名是朱莉娅·努内斯。这是他们多年前曾经一起翻唱的一首歌。
Act Three, And If You See Her, Tell Her It's Over Now. In this last act, we turn from small, personal moments to big news that the whole world experiences, but that hits some people very, very personally. You probably saw the headlines and reports that a couple of weeks ago, after his family ruled Syria for over 50 years, the president/dictator Bashar Al Assad, was run out of his own country very suddenly.
第三幕，如果你看见她，告诉她一切都结束了。在这一最后幕中，我们从个人的小瞬间转向整个世界都在经历的大新闻，但这对某些人来说影响非常、非常个人化。你们可能看到了头条新闻和报道，就在几周前，在他家族统治叙利亚超过50年后，总统兼独裁者巴沙尔·阿萨德非常突然地被赶出了自己的国家。
Assad ran a government that did not tolerate dissent. He used chemical weapons against his own citizens. He spent much of the last 13 years brutally crushing an uprising. Hundreds of thousands of Syrians were killed, tortured, disappeared.
阿萨德领导的政府不容忍任何异议。他对自己的人民使用了化学武器。在过去13年里，他大部分时间都在残酷地镇压起义。数十万叙利亚人被杀害、拷打、失踪。
More than half the population was displaced in that conflict. Six million Syrians fled the country. So when a rebel coalition forced Assad out two weeks ago, Syrians all over the globe had their world turned upside down, and a few of us here at the show called around to see what that's been like for them. Diane Wu put together this story.
在那场冲突中，超过一半的人口流离失所。六百万叙利亚人逃离了该国。因此，当反叛联盟两周前迫使阿萨德下台时，全球各地的叙利亚人的世界都发生了翻天覆地的变化，我们节目组的几个人打电话去询问这对他们来说是什么样的感受。戴安·吴整理了这个故事。
The regime collapsed late on a Saturday night. My coworkers and I talked to a few Syrians who are living abroad now about what that night was like for them. One was up studying for an exam. Another was out to an anniversary dinner. He kept checking his phone.
政权在周六深夜崩溃了。我和同事们采访了几位现在住在国外的叙利亚人，了解那个夜晚对他们来说是什么样的。有人当时正熬夜复习考试。有人当时正在参加结婚周年纪念晚宴。他不停地查看手机。
But the person I want to tell you about is Salma. She was in London on Saturday. She lives in another part of England. But watching the news by herself in the days before that, she felt like she had to be around other Syrians. So she got on the train and headed to her friend's apartment. She'd been crashing there since Thursday.
但我最想讲述的是萨尔玛。周六她人在伦敦。她住在英格兰的另一个地方。但在那之前的几天里，她独自看着新闻，感到自己必须和其他叙利亚人在一起。于是她坐上火车，前往朋友的公寓。她从周四开始就一直挤在那里。
It's like this tiny one-- it's not even an apartment. It's like a studio. So it's this tiny, tiny studio. We're all sitting together on this couch, five of us, and we're all, like, on our phones. And then the TV's on, and we're all checking, and there's barely any space. I don't know if I would describe it as crashing, because we didn't sleep. So--
就像这小小的……甚至算不上公寓。就是一个单间。我们五个人挤在这张沙发上，全都盯着手机。电视开着，我们都在检查，几乎没有任何空间。我不知道我是否会形容为“挤住”，因为我们没睡觉。所以……
(LAUGHING) OK.
（笑声）好的。
(LAUGHING) --none of us were sleeping, actually. It felt like we were on duty for some reason, like we were on call constantly.
（笑声）……实际上我们谁都没睡觉。感觉我们出于某种原因在值班，好像我们时刻在待命。
It felt like their job to not look away. Something huge was happening back home. The rebels kept taking more and more ground each day, liberating more and more cities with hardly any pushback. Everyone was worried that Assad would do something desperate, like retaliate with chemical weapons or bombings, or that Russia would jump in. Salma and her friends were barely keeping it together.
他们觉得不去关注是他们的职责。家乡正在发生巨大的变化。反叛军每天夺取的领土越来越多，解放的城市也越来越多，几乎没有遇到什么阻力。每个人都担心阿萨德会做出绝望的行为，比如用化学武器或爆炸进行报复，或者俄罗斯会介入。萨尔玛和她的朋友们几乎快要崩溃了。
One of them-- it's not funny, but he kept fainting. And so-- [LAUGHS] he would go into the room, and then just, like, almost pass out. So the first thing I did was-- I didn't know what to do, so I gave him a tomato with salt on it, and I just shoved it into his mouth.
他们中的一个——这并不好笑，但他不停地晕倒。所以……（笑声）他会走进房间，然后就直接……几乎昏过去。所以我做的第一件事就是——我不知道该怎么办，所以我给了他一个撒了盐的番茄，我就把它塞进他嘴里。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And I was like, OK, I think your blood pressure is dropping. And--
我说，好的，我想你的血压在下降。而且……
And were you guys like-- were you worried or freaked out, or was he kind of like, oh, this is something that happens?
你们当时是……你们感到担心或恐慌吗，还是他那种，噢，这是经常发生的事情？
We were-- I don't think we were super freaked out, just because a lot of us have medical training. [CHUCKLES]
我们……我不认为我们超级恐慌，只是因为我们很多人都有医学培训。（轻笑）
(LAUGHING) OK.
（笑声）好的。
It wasn't that big of a deal. And so--
这没什么大不了的。所以……
That's handy. [LAUGHS] OK.
那很方便。（笑声）好的。
Yeah.
是的。
They notice there is a pattern to his fainting. First, he'd start sweating profusely, then go stand in the door to cool off, then head towards the bathroom.
他们注意到他晕倒有规律可循。首先，他开始大量出汗，然后去门口冷却一下，接着走向洗手间。
By the third time, we kind of got the routine down. Like, we saw him open the door. We're like, he's about to pass out. Like, someone start, you know-- [LAUGHS] doing all the steps.
到第三次时，我们有点掌握了流程。就像，我们看到他打开门。我们心想，他要昏倒了。就像，有人开始，你知道……（笑声）采取所有步骤。
We kept joking. They're like, we have to-- you can't pass out now. You got to be strong. You got to make it until the regime falls.
我们一直在开玩笑。他们说，我们必须……你现在不能昏倒。你必须坚强。你必须坚持到政权垮台。
Salma told me that her friend who kept fainting had been detained by the regime when he was a teenager, three times. He fled Syria after the third time, but his parents are still there, and he was really concerned about them. Other people in the room were also having physical reactions from all the stress and fear.
萨尔玛告诉我，她那个一直晕倒的朋友在十几岁时就被政权拘留过，三次。他在第三次之后逃离了叙利亚，但他的父母还在那里，他非常担心他们。屋里的其他人也因为所有的压力和恐惧而产生了身体反应。
I think it was just, like, our bodies going into shock, and each person was kind of doing it differently. Like, for me, I cry a lot, and I have panic attacks, and then I throw up, which is kind of gross. But that's what would happen to me. Like, I would get really nauseous, really nauseous, really nauseous. Like, I would go and throw up.
我想这只是我们的身体进入了休克状态，每个人表现的方式不同。比如，对我来说，我哭了很多，我有恐慌发作，然后我呕吐，这有点恶心。但这确实发生在我身上。就像，我会变得非常恶心，非常恶心，非常恶心。就像，我会去呕吐。
It was from inside this crowded apartment, scattered with takeout containers and nervous bodies, that these friends then witnessed a sudden unraveling that none of them had anticipated. Salma is from Damascus, the capital, which was the seat of the Assad regime.
正是从这个挤满外卖盒和焦虑身体的公寓里，这些朋友们目睹了一场他们谁也没料到的突然瓦解。萨尔玛来自大马士革，那是首都，是阿萨德政权的所在地。
And as the rebels kept advancing across Syria, taking Hama, and then As-Suwayda, and then Homs, her friends from those cities celebrated around her. If the rebels succeeded, her hometown would be the last to fall. When Salma saw a video of people standing on a tank in Umayyad Square in Damascus, singing "Jannah Jannah," a revolutionary song, it was finally real to her. It was over.
随着反叛军在叙利亚各地推进，攻占哈马，然后是苏韦达，然后是霍姆斯，她来自那些城市的朋友们在她周围欢呼。如果反叛军成功了，她的家乡将是最后一个倒下的。当萨尔玛看到一段视频，视频里人们站在大马士革倭马亚广场的一辆坦克上，唱着“天堂，天堂”（Jannah Jannah），这是一首革命歌曲，对她来说，这终于成真了。一切都结束了。
Knowing that we would be the last, I was holding it in. And so the first thing I did was, I cried, I hugged all my friends, I-- I sat there kind of staring at the wall, crying, crying, crying, crying.
知道我们将会是最后一个，我一直忍着。所以我做的第一件事就是，我哭了，我拥抱了所有的朋友，我……我坐在那儿盯着墙，哭啊，哭啊，哭啊，哭啊。
They stayed up all night, and then celebrated more the next day in Trafalgar Square. Then Salma went home and mostly laid in bed in the dark for a few days, trying to make sense of this brand-new world. Salma's family had left Damascus in the first year of the war, 2011, when she was 15.
他们通宵未眠，第二天在特拉法加广场进行了更多庆祝。然后萨尔玛回家，在黑暗中躺了几天，试图理解这个全新的世界。萨尔玛一家在战争的第一年，2011年，她15岁时就离开了大马士革。
They moved to Connecticut, where she joined the soccer team and tried to do regular life while going to protests against the regime on weekends. Now, she had to figure out how to reverse this thing she's been doing since she was a teenager, separating herself from Syria.
他们搬到了康涅狄格州，她在那里加入了足球队，试图过正常生活，同时在周末参加反对政权的抗议活动。现在，她必须弄清楚如何扭转她从十几岁起一直在做的事情——将自己与叙利亚隔绝。
I knew I couldn't go back, with the regime there. And so I started slowly distancing myself from my memories. Like, before, I would post a lot of photos, saying, I miss Damascus, or I miss this, or I miss my house, and I miss that. And I stopped doing that, kind of on purpose. And even between myself when I'm alone, if I would remember something or if I would find myself kind of daydreaming, I would stop myself, and I wouldn't let myself go through with it.
我知道政权在那里，我回不去了。于是我开始慢慢疏远我的记忆。比如，以前，我会发布很多照片，说，我想念大马士革，我想念这个，或者我想念我的房子。但我停止了这样做，有点刻意为之。即使当我独自一人时，如果我记起什么，或者如果我发现自己在发呆，我会阻止自己，不让自己继续下去。
What kind of daydream?
什么样的发呆？
Like, sometimes, I would daydream about my house and, like-- (CRYING) sorry.
比如，有时，我会梦到我的房子，然后……（哭泣）抱歉。
It's OK.
没关系。
Yeah, I don't know. Like, it's the place where I have a lot of good memories, and-- and it's the place where me and my siblings did this and did that. And sometimes, I would just daydream about walking into my room and going back and sitting in my living room and looking out the window. And I just-- I wouldn't let myself do that anymore. And even at times where I would have dreams about being in my house again, I would wake myself up and be like, no, this isn't real.
是的，我不知道。就像，那是我有很多美好回忆的地方，而且……那是我和兄弟姐妹们一起做这个做那个的地方。有时，我只是发呆地想象走进我的房间，回去坐在我的客厅里，看着窗外。我只是……我不让自己那样做了。甚至有时我做梦梦到我又在我的房子里了，我会把自己唤醒，心想，不，这不是真的。
Someone else I talked to described it like this. Syria was on a different planet from the one he lived on now. There was no way to visit it. He had to flip a page, start a new life. Better not to think about it anymore.
我采访的另一个人这样描述它。叙利亚就像在他现在生活的星球之外的另一个星球。根本没法去访问。他必须翻过这一页，开始新生活。最好还是别再想它了。
But now that the regime was suddenly gone, Syria was back on this planet, a place like any other place. And they had to reset their minds to take that in, which was hard to do after so many years of doing the opposite. Salma started thinking about visiting home, not just in a dream way, but the logistics of where she would stay when she went back.
但现在政权突然倒台了，叙利亚又回到了这个星球上，一个和其他地方一样的地方。他们必须重置思想来接受这一点，在做了这么多年的相反事情之后，这很难做到。萨尔玛开始考虑回国探亲，不仅仅是梦里的那种，而是具体的物流问题，回国后她住哪里。
So we still have our house now. I'm like, would I stay at my house, or would I want to stay somewhere else? Or what am I going to do? And now, I can think of all the plans.
所以我们现在还有房子。我心想，我会住在家里吗，还是想住在别处？或者我要做什么？现在，我可以开始制定所有的计划了。
The euphoria of the regime falling was laced with heavy feelings, too. In the days following the collapse, as Salma learned just how many people who'd been disappeared by the Assad government had been killed were not coming home, she had another panic attack.
政权倒台的欣快感中也夹杂着沉重的情绪。在崩溃后的几天里，当萨尔玛了解到有多少被阿萨德政府消失的人已经被杀害，而且再也回不来时，她又产生了一次恐慌发作。
Salma's been watching all kinds of videos coming out of the new Syria, and there's a particular type that delights her-- one I wasn't expecting.
萨尔玛一直在看从新叙利亚出来的各种视频，有一种特别的类型让她感到高兴——一种我没料到的。
It was a girl in a karate uniform. And this guy was standing across from her with something on his head-- I can't remember-- like a water bottle. And she closes her eyes, and she, like, karate-kicks the water bottle off the top of his head with her eyes closed. And then the camera pans back, and everyone's, like, clapping and cheering.
那是一个穿着空手道服的女孩。一个男人站在她对面，头上顶着什么东西——我不记得了——比如一个水瓶。她闭上眼睛，闭着眼一脚把男人头顶的水瓶踢飞了。然后摄像机镜头拉开，每个人都在鼓掌和欢呼。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I saw people doing parkour in Damascus. They're doing, like, back flips in the street in the middle of the celebration.
我看到人们在大马士革做跑酷。他们在庆祝活动中在街上做后空翻。
Watching these people just be silly and happy-- for Salma, she sees that as getting to watch them finally be free.
看着这些人只是单纯的傻乐和快乐——对萨尔玛来说，她觉得这是看着他们终于获得了自由。
In Latakia, someone was lifting weights.
在拉塔基亚，有人在举重。
Like, in the street?
就像在街上？
Like, in the street. Yeah, like, in the middle of this. There's fighters, kind of, passing by on cars, waving flowers, and he's right on the side, doing all of these moves-- [LAUGHS] in his, like, gym clothes. It's just so, so unserious, so fun.
就像，在街上。是的，就像，在这一片欢腾中。有武装人员开着车经过，挥舞着鲜花，他就站在旁边，做着这些动作……（笑声）穿着他那种，健身服。这太，太不严肃了，太有趣了。
It's things you could have done before, but it's just the mentality of, you're free, you can do anything, and you belong to this country, or it feels like it's yours again. I think the slogans of the regime were so damaging to our psyche, like calling it Suria al Asad-- Assad's Syria-- just-- it removes you from the equation.
这是你以前也能做的事情，但这只是那种心态——你自由了，你可以做任何事，你属于这个国家，或者感觉它又变回你的了。我觉得政权的口号对我们的心理造成了很大伤害，比如把它叫作“阿萨德的叙利亚”（Suria al Asad）——阿萨德的叙利亚——这把你从这个等式中剔除了。
So who are you in Assad's Syria? You're nobody. You don't belong. Seeing the people now in Syria, seeing their reaction, they're slowly kind of feeling like it is theirs-- this is our country. We're the ones who are responsible for it now. We're the ones who are going to take care of it.
那么在阿萨德的叙利亚里你是谁？你是无名小卒。你不属于这儿。现在看到叙利亚的人民，看到他们的反应，他们慢慢地感觉到它属于他们——这是我们的国家。我们才是负责它的人。我们才是要照顾它的人。
There's pretty much no way to overstate how much there is to do next, how many things will need to be figured out, how many unknowns there are. But one person told me, none of it could be worse than what we lived through already.
几乎没有办法去夸大接下来还有多少事情要做，有多少事情需要弄清楚，有多少未知数。但有人告诉我，没有什么能比我们已经经历过的一切更糟糕了。
Diane Wu is a producer on our show. This story was co-produced by Hany Hawasly.
戴安·吴是我们节目的制片人。这个故事是由哈尼·哈瓦斯利共同制作的。
That's Mike and Julia covering Weezer's Sweater Song, "Undone."
这就是迈克和朱莉娅翻唱威瑟的毛衣歌《解开》（Undone）。
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Cassie Howie, Chana Joffe-Walt, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
我们今天的节目由莉莉·沙利文制作。参与今天节目制作的人员包括菲娅·贝宁、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、卡西·豪伊、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、亨利·拉尔森、塞斯·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、娜迪亚·雷曼、安东尼·罗曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。
Our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Natalie Sullivan, Kim Sullivan, Sarah Kim, Steve Sopchak, Erin Maree Comite, Dave Burns, Todd Johnson, Leanne Victorine, Darien Woods, and Yazan Abou Ismail. To become a This American Life Partner, which gets you bonus content, ad-free listening, and hundreds of our favorite episodes of the shown in your podcast feed, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢娜塔莉·沙利文、金·沙利文、莎拉·金、史蒂夫·索普查克、艾琳·玛丽·科米特、戴夫·伯恩斯、托德·约翰逊、莉安·维克多琳、达里恩·伍兹和亚赞·阿布·伊斯梅尔。要成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴，从而获得额外内容、无广告收听以及我们播客中数百个最爱剧集，请访问 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目说明中。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He invented this new appetizer where you put a hot dog in a handful of straw. What's he call it?
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他发明了一种新的开胃菜，就是把热狗插在一把稻草里。他管这叫什么？
Hey, dawg!
嘿，老兄！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。